Yo, c'est Cyrus et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode du Coup de Phil
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous raconter une histoire
Alors, je vous ai déjà raconté des mythes dans mes anciennes vidéos
mais je ne vous ai jamais fait un Coup de Phil en entier sur un mythe.
Eh bien, c'est sur le point de changer puisqu'aujourd'hui on va parler du mythe de Prométhée.
Alors, il y a différentes versions du mythe de Prométhée
Moi, je vais parler de celle de Platon dans "Protagoras"
On va d'abord l'exposer, et ensuite essayer d'aller un petit peu plus loin.
Et pour l'autre version, vous la trouverez dans la description.
(Toujours checker la desciption de mes vidéos!)
En gros, il y a très, très, très longtemps, les dieux ont créé des espèces mortelles :
les hommes, et les animaux.
Ils l'ont fait à base de terre et de feu.
Déjà, ça part mal parce qu'avec de la terre et du feu
au mieux, si t'es très balèze, t'obtiens ça.
Et j'espère qu'on ressemble pas à ça.
Et là, ils ont demandé à deux titans
(les titans c'est des êtres divins qui étaient là avant les dieux de l'Olympe, hyper géants et hyper balèzes)
et ces deux titans, c'est Epiméthée et Prométhée.
Ils leur ont demandé de faire le partage des caractéristiques et des qualités de ces êtres mortels.
Voix off : "Bon vous partagez ça bien ok ? Vous me le Prométhée ?
Non sérieux, bon courage hein... Epiméthée la dose !
Epiméthée...comme ton prénom en fait..."
- "Non mais c'est pas drôle en fait.
- On me le dit titan!"
Epiméthée, dont le nom veut dire "celui qui réfléchit après coup",
veut faire le partage tout seul et Prométhée accepte.
Ça sent la merde, là, ou pas ?
Non, parce que le mec s'appelle "celui qui réfléchit après coup",
soit parce que ses parents sont des bâtards, soit parce que c'est vrai,
et on lui confie le partage des qualités des êtres mortels ?!
Du coup, le mec fait son partage, et il le fait bien :
il donne à certaines espèces la force, à d'autres la vitesse,
pas au mêmes espèces parce que sinon ça va créer un déséquilibre
et il y aura des espèces bien avantagées par rapport à d'autres ;
les espèces qui n'ont pas d'armes vont pouvoir s'envoler facilement
ou s'engouffrer sous terre pour se protéger ;
les proies pourront se reproduire beaucoup plus facilement que les prédateurs ;
et puis en fonction d'où elles sont les espèces vont avoir du pelage, des écailles, etc.
En gros, super bien pensé.
"Il me reste des ailes, des poils, et des palmes...
Ah bah, tiens, j'ai qu'à lui mettre les ailes et les poils ?
Ah bah, non, c'est pas possible...
ouais, mais je lui ai déjà mis un bec de canard...
Vas-y, il est 4h du mat', tant pis...or-ni-tho-rynque."
- Mec, t'es au courant que ça s'est pas du tout passé comme ça ?
- Oui, oui.
- Non, mais là c'est pas du tout scientifique ton truc !
- Non, mais c'est un mythe ! C'est une histoire !
- Ouais, mais tu sais que c'est l'inverse ?
- Léo...
- Ouais ?
- C'est un mythe, les gens le savent, t'inquiète.
- OK, précise-le quand même."
Alors, je vais quand même faire une petite précision pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
la théorie de l'évolution des espèces :
c'est effectivement l'inverse qui s'est passé.
C'est-à dire que, schématiquement, les espèces avaient des caractéristiques,
et celles qui ont survécu sont celles qui avaient un environnement favorable à ces caractéristiques.
Et c'est pas, comme dit le mythe de Prométhée,
genre, suivant leur environnement, on va leur donner certaines caractéristiques.
C'est l'inverse qui s'est passé.
Mais non seulement c'est quelque chose que Platon ne savait pas,
et en plus c'est un mythe, donc un truc pas très vrai de base.
Du coup, et c'est là qu'on arrive à la bêtise,
Epiméthée oublie les humains dans son partage.
Nous, on se retrouve à poil, sans arme, sans aile, bref : nuls.
Du coup, Prométhée quand il voit ça, il est pas très content.
- Non mais en fait je pensais qu'il me restait des qualités, là...je sais pas trop où je les ai mises...
- Ta gueule.
- Oui.
Et Prométhée, qui veut dire "celui qui réfléchit avant"
(même s'il réfléchissait vraiment avant, il aurait peut-être pas laissé faire son frère
qui s'appelle "celui qui réfléchit après"),
décide de sauver les Hommes et de voler un truc qui appartient aux dieux :
il décide de voler la connaissance des Arts et le feu,
parce que la connaissance des Arts sans le feu
c'est quand même extrêmement limité,
vu que c'est le feu qui t'aide à quasiment tout construire à la base.
Du coup, il part en cachette voler le feu et l'habileté technique
auprès d'Héphaïstos, le dieu du feu,
et d'Athéna, la déesse de la sagesse et des artistes.
Et en gros pour Platon ce sont Héphaïstos et Athéna qui sont, ensemble, les dieux de la "technè",
c'est-à-dire de l'art et de la technique.
- "Voilà, j'ai le feu et la connaissance des Arts !
- Cool... Tu pouvais pas ramener un slip ?"
Alors parenthèse, je précise que Zeus s'est vénère et a décidé de punir Prométhée.
Mais pas qu'un peu parce qu'il l'attache sur une montagne dans le Caucase
et qu'un aigle vient lui bouffer son foie, qui repousse tous les jours.
Donc là les Hommes commencent à faire des trucs de fou,
comme se construire des armes ou des maisons,
mais ils sont quand même dominés par les loups, les ours, les fauves,
tout simplement parce qu'ils sont isolés.
A cette époque, les villes n'existaient pas,
et quand les Hommes se réunissaient, ils se tapaient dessus.
Du coup, Zeus regarde ça et il a peur que notre race ne survive pas.
Donc il appelle Hermès et lui demande de nous donner la Pudeur et la Justice,
pour qu'on puisse créer des sociétés.
Maintenant, reste à savoir comment ça se distribue,
parce que l'art ça s'est distribué de manière bien spécifique :
en gros il y a les experts, mais tout le monde ne maîtrise pas l'art de la guerre
ou l'art médical.
Sauf que là Zeus dit à Hermès :
"Ok, moi je veux que t'en donne à tout le monde
parce que sinon on pourra pas faire de villes."
Et pour Platon, c'est pour ça que sur des sujets d'expertise,
tout le monde n'a pas la légitimité de donner son avis
alors que pour la politique tout le monde peut s'exprimer.
*brouhaha*
- "Patron vous êtes sûr que c'était une bonne idée d'en filer à tout le monde ?
Non parce qu'il y a Michel de la compta qui pense avoir une licence en géopolitique là.
Voix off : Oui, c'est important que tout le monde puisse parler, après on est pas obligé de les écouter, hein.
- Ouf, j'ai eu peur... Me refaites pas ça patron."
Il y a plusieurs points qui se dégagent de ce mythe :
déjà, les animaux et les Hommes sont nettement séparés d'emblée, ils n'ont pas le même traitement.
Par exemple les animaux ont des caractéristiques et des qualités qui viennent d’Épiméthée,
alors que nous ça vient directement des dieux mon pote...et ouais.
Donc nous on a quelque chose de l'ordre du divin,
et ça les animaux ne l'ont pas.
Voix off : "Alors je parle bien de ce que nous dit ce mythe,
non parce que je te vois venir au fond, à crier au spécisme...
ouais si je t'ai vu !
Ensuite, si on s'attarde un petit peu sur les connaissances du divin,
eh bien on a la connaissance de l'Art,
et c'est l'art au sens grec, c'est-à-dire la technè.
En gros, c'est pas juste faire des tableaux :
la rhétorique est un art, l'ingénierie est un art...
En fait, tout ce qui requiert de la technique est un art.
Je pense que je ferais une vidéo dessus un jour.
Prométhée va l'amener avec le feu, et si on s'en rend compte, c'est quand même
l'outil qui va nous permettre de créer les autres outils.
En gros, le feu, c'est la raison, et plus largement, l'intelligence.
Après, c'est intéressant de voir que le mythe dégage clairement deux dimensions :
d'abord la dimension technique que nous donne Prométhée,
c'est-à-dire la connaissance de l'art et l'intelligence,
et la dimension morale, que nous donne Zeus via Hermès,
c'est-à-dire la pudeur et la justice.
De la même façon, "pudeur" (aidôs en grec), c'est plus large que le sens qu'on en a aujourd’hui.
Non parce que sinon c'est chelou.
Voix off : "Tu leur envoie la justice et surtout la pudeur,
j'en ai ras le cul de les voir de promener à poil."
- Dommage.
Non, parce que "aidôs" est une notion qui regroupe des choses
comme l'honneur et le respect.
De la même façon, la justice, c'est plus large, là.
On parle aussi de coutumes et de droit.
Donc le fait qu'il y ait d'un côté une dimension technique
et de l'autre une dimension morale,
et que les deux soient bien séparés dans le mythe,
c'est bien vu et totalement vrai,
car ce sont deux choses totalement dissociées.
Par exemple, on fait des découvertes scientifiques d'abord
et on se pose des question morales ou éthiques après.
Et c'est aussi marrant de voir que le mythe a précédé des découvertes paléontologiques :
on nous dit dans le mythe que toutes les sociétés ont l'art, la technique, la raison, où qu'elles soient.
En tout cas, si vous voulez avoir d'autres qualités divines super cool,
sachez que les dieux de l'Olympe m'ont chargé de vous inviter
à vous abonner à cette chaîne pour ne rater aucun épisode
et surtout à passer le coup de Phil' à un ami,
parce que les idées les plus fortes, c'est les idées partagées.
Je vous envoie du love, et de la peace.
Yolo !
Merci à Léo de la chaîne Dirty Biology :
quand j'ai écrit le script, je me suis dit qu'il serait fou
en lisant tout ça,
donc, c'était normal de l'appeler,
et si vous connaissez pas, n'hésitez pas à aller voir sa chaîne,
c'est très intéressant
Comme d'habitude, on se retrouve dans deux semaines,
je vous laisse me rejoindre sur Facebook et Twitter,
deux plateformes sur lesquelles
je balance des contenus exclusifs relativement différents,
donc ça peut valoir le coup d'y aller,
et Snapchat où je raconte ma vie,
vous le savez pour ceux qui me suivent.
Yolo !